ladies and gentlemen please welcome our
guest of honor Sheikh Hamdan bin
Mohammed bin Rashid Al Maktoum grand
Prince of Dubai thank you your highness
[Music]
[Music]
the global teacher prize goes to Nancy
actually I've learned and I'm still
learning how to make a school a place of
happiness and wisdom ambien Felicita a
la maestra hanan al group
zoom Allah Allah Allah Linum secured a
beard or Hudnall Islands Italian nonno
Noah haidle alum Vitaly
Maggie McDonald
[Music]
[Applause]
this is for all the top 50s out there
teachers teachers
[Applause]
Andreea Zafira coo
tonight it's not about one person it's
about celebrating all the teachers and
recognizing the important role they play
in shaping the future for our children
[Applause]
your highness distinguished guests
ladies and gentlemen please welcome Her
Excellency Sarah bint Yusuf Allah Miri
cabinet member and Minister of State for
advanced Sciences for the UAE star
American good evening your highness
Sheikh Hamdan Hamad Al Maktoum Crown
Prince of Dubai sunny Varkey chairman of
the Warka foundation your excellencies
distinguished guests it gives me a great
pleasure to welcome you today to the
global teacher prize that honors the
best teachers from all around the world
teachers shaped lives and mold our
future they are the invisible hand in
society and they can create great
citizens of humanity as many of us do I
have a story with a teacher who with a
few words shaped my future in the eighth
grade
my Arabic teacher called me into the
office and simply said I checked your
grades I've spoken to your others too to
your other teachers and all of us agree
you are a good student and that is the
problem
because you can be a great student you
have great potential and you are
destined for great things
and we are puzzled about why you are
holding yourself back that day I learned
my most valuable lesson from a great
teacher who went above and beyond the
call of duty
I learned that we are all our own worst
enemies and that our limiting beliefs
are what hold us back those words had a
profound impact on my life that moment
elevated me it expanded my horizons it
provided me with the foundations to
dream great to act upon those audacious
dreams it sheds all of my insecurities
to my teacher
thank you I am here today because of
your words this is what great teachers
do they provide a boundless canvas for
dreams to be drawn on like great leaders
they understand the strengths of their
students and tap into on its an untapped
potential they extract it and give their
students the opportunity to grow to
every teacher in my son's life you are
an integral part of my family from a
parent thank you for all that you do for
my son hotted thank you for every time
he surprises me with an act of kindness
a thought and a dream that I knew that
you were a central part of and I would
also like to thank Highness Sheikh
Mohammed bin Rashid Al Maktoum for being
a great teacher in leadership and for
teaching us and showing us that
impossible is not a word in our
dictionary and too sunny Varkey and the
Warka foundation thank you for bringing
teachers to the center stage with this
award and to all the teachers in the
audience today thank you for making the
world a better place one student at a
time
and now ladies and gentlemen a special
message from Lord Andrew Lloyd Webber
your highness your excellencies ladies
and gentlemen good evening
I wish I could be with you in person to
this beautiful celebration I know you're
in for a treat this evening because I've
heard that tonight's shows as good as
anything you'll see on the West End or
on Broadway so enjoy when I first heard
about the global teacher prize I thought
it was a simple and wonderful way to
help people see the important
contribution the teachers make
throughout the world
both my parents were music teachers and
I saw firsthand the effort and skill
involved in their work it made me
recognize that teachers deserve far more
praise and they sometimes receive so I
am very glad that knew ten finalists are
being recognized on the world stage for
your dedication and your talent to be on
that stage you have to have worked hard
improved the lives of many young people
and laid the groundwork for their future
achievements today as I fear we all know
education is under threat all over the
world from funding shortages lack of
resources and importantly too few
teachers this is particularly true in
the case of music education where many
young people lack access to instruments
tuition and opportunities to perform
through my foundation and the music in
secondary schools trusts we try to help
supply some of those needs in the UK but
we can only do a little bit so wherever
you live in the world if you were
involved in education or you were in a
position to make a difference please
consider supporting music tuition and
musical life in schools
it creates well-rounded young people
it's not about turning them necessarily
into musicians great if they do but it's
about making them empowered and music
can empower them all sorts of unexpected
ways with that thought I hope 2019 will
be an excellent year for you all and a
great year for the global teacher prize
I would like to extend my warmest
congratulations this year's 10 marvelous
finalists and every inspiring teacher in
the world
I offer my personal thanks to His
Highness Sheikh Mohammed bin Rashid Al
Maktoum for his continued patronage of
the
teacher price I would also like to thank
sunny Varkey and the Varkey foundation
for doing so much to support the work of
teachers around the world thank you and
good night
ladies and gentlemen now to announce the
ten finalists for the 2019 global
teacher prize mr. Hugh Jackman ladies
and gentlemen it is now my great
pleasure to announce the top 10
finalists for the global teacher prize
for 2019 they are and room offered from
the United Kingdom a big challenge for
us is teaching our children that there
are different people out there there has
been a sort lies in racist and a
religious hate crime this is a resource
that helps schools teach children that
we're all different but actually that's
fantastic
Daisy mertens from the Netherlands you
don't need computers or other resources
it's for free to listen to children so
that's what we want to achieve that
adults and children work together more
and then from the bottom up you have
ownership of your own future and you can
create your own future
Deborah Garofalo from Brazil who else is
motorised was sustained know so much for
the robotic in town Elm trouble you
decree achieve a dodge Meister main
gesture Sisu to paint a main to a Vida
Bailey's for vintage official turkey
grasses I Ibuka so Elif I transform and
miss premier said profesora de Diez he D
Kazu Shoto from Japan no Japanese
English only ever okay alright let's go
I figured out that why not March
together English and information
technology I want to spread minecraft
project all over Japan perfect
Martin sell Betty from Argentina
radiocommunication tienen que ser para
la vista da moneh radio community Luka
TiVo reponse a vida de trabajar
pensando Chico's okay no Chico's on your
fedora pienso que la mejor nope no co2 a
via Napoleon Melissa salgueiro from the
United States my students they helped
pick me up they came to me with lyrics
and I said I have to give this a voice
my students open up to me
and it's so important that you just
listen my kids deserve to be seen and
heard and I love them
Peter to be she from Kenya I just want
to have a positive impact not only in my
country even the whole of Africa caring
for people is in my heart
we need the peace in our communities we
need peace in our hearts to be a great
teacher you have to do more and talk
less soir au revoir from India the
teacher is Bill one makes a huge
difference in the children's self-esteem
in one village love goodra all the girls
took a vow never to get married till
they were 18 I want my children to be
equipped with life skills that not only
make them resilient but emotionally
empowered Vladimir up Kesava from
georgia Scolari Sarasota charity Natalie
civilian Angela Transco lento fellows
who are trained masala absorbers Transco
lashes and masa de la Valliere Oh II
Brazil I'm Teresa blemishes shamed
excuses goddess SS Teresa Peppa the
squats yesterday is seldom a turn from
Australia I absolutely love my job
working with students for them to
understand the world and their place in
it
we are constantly telling our students
that it's not where they come from
it's where they're going to go the whole
communities and all
the world can be transformed through the
way that we do things every day and I'd
like to give special thanks to His
Highness Sheikh Mohammed bin Rashid Al
Maktoum vice president and prime
minister of the United Arab Emirates and
ruler of Dubai under whose continued
patronage the global teacher prize has
become a shining beacon for teachers
around the world I'd also like to thank
sunny Varkey and the Varkey foundation
for giving us such a powerful
celebration of the work of teachers and
their commitment to education throughout
the world since the launch of the global
teacher prize in Dubai UAE just five
years ago it has gone on to inspire over
30 national teacher prizes and I think
thousands of stories of heroes that have
transformed young people's lives ladies
and gentlemen having a fantastic night
best of luck to the 10 finalists I
really really wish I could be with you
there in person tonight you know what
it's it must be quite a few award
ceremonies in my time but it's the
greatest privilege to be able to
celebrate the work of teachers not just
you guys here but teachers around the
globe there is no job that is more
important
and tonight gives us a chance to thank
those who don't get thanked enough for
doing such an incredible job so not a
lot of people know this but when I was
18 I left high school and at my school
they had a program where two students
had the chance to go to London to work
as a member of staff in in London miles
from Australia was a big deal that's in
two of us we each had six months at the
school and that's where I really learned
what it meant to be a teacher
I mean I was just a teacher's assistant
but to watch how hard teachers work
every single day the hours of
preparation just to put into a one-hour
class the service the care they took for
each and every student it was humbling
and I of course did not go into teaching
but the other gentleman who actually was
in the school for the other six months
he went into teaching and this is a
coincidence but he ended up becoming two
years ago a top 50 finalists in the
Varkey foundation and he happens to be
here tonight mr. Cameron Patterson stand
up arrow
petter don't worry mate I won't tell any
war stories it's okay you can relax but
if I won't for the teachers in my life I
wouldn't be standing on this stage today
teachers they could Joel you they push
you they encourage you they pick you off
the floor when you literally can't get
up they they inspire you and if it
wasn't for these 10 finalists here on
this stage tonight none of us would be
in this room your highness your
excellencies ladies and gentlemen we put
on a show that I hope you enjoyed but I
think we'll all agree the real stars on
stage tonight are these 10 teachers now
only only one of you unfortunately is
actually going to be holding that trophy
in about ten minutes five minutes from
now but I think we can all agree that
all of you are winners here tonight
every single one of you you have all
achieved beyond measure
you have given from your hearts to
tirelessly for years and years to each
and every kid that's come into your care
you have showed passion you show
dedication you have showed love and it's
an inspiration to all of us a lot of you
working in places where life is very
very tough but you teach young people
how to stand center stage in their own
life story all of you and every
dedicated teacher around the world is
shaping the next generation Andrew you
look great mate in the tux the bowtie
you teach kids to be proud of where they
come from at the same time to be
tolerant and to be accepting of people
who may look different they may believe
in different things who may come from
different places Daisy
you said something in your video that
really touched me you said all of us
have scars but let's not be defined by
the past in our lives let's be defined
by where we are going and you shared a
story that you'd had a tough upbringing
but school was a safe haven for you and
you've gone on to dedicate your life to
making sure school is a safe haven the
and every kid that comes into your care
it's amazing Deborah Deborah from some
Paulo Brazil
Deborah don't cry yet we got a long way
to go it's okay you are incredible you
work in an area which is difficult for
some a lot of those kids have really
really difficult lives but you teach
them to look beyond to the whole globe
to take care of this planet at the same
time you you show them that it's
important to connect locally to connect
to their community and no matter what
they're going through you take care of
each and every one as oh they're your
own it's amazing because oh come on come
on petty Kazu you teach foreign
languages to students when you were
young your parents didn't have the funds
for you to be able to travel abroad so
now as a teacher you make sure no matter
what situation kids are coming from you
make it not only possible for them to
learn the language that you're offering
you make it fun you make it fun you use
computer games you use robots I wish I
was you and my teacher when I was
learning French for three years and
really all I've learned is costs all
it's really not very helpful but
honestly it's amazing what you do Martin
you taught me a new word tonight fart
fart cha cha cha means eleganza you are
the essence of elegance my friend in
your school 20 years ago you created a
radio station so you made sure that the
kids could find voice though they could
campaign about things that was really
important to them on top of that you
decided to start a program where you
taught the kids how to fix motorcycles
and on top of that you said once you fix
the motorcycle we're going to deliver
them to the poorest of the poor in our
communities so the people who are still
with a horse and a cart can now have a
motorcycle you're a hero
really congratulations Melissa
Melissa I know you're gonna cry it's
okay let's just stay here just hug it
out Melissa you teach music which is
obviously dear to my heart music is
everybody's joy whether you're talented
or not and so that's the approach you're
gonna make me cry stop it
you make sure that any kid comes to you
and says I want to be in the band miss
they're in the band if the if they
haven't been to one practice and the
concert is on that night you say you're
in the band no problem when you arrived
at the school there was not one musical
instrument you now even despite the
school being broken into all those years
ago and every instrument being stolen
you have raised over $200,000 to make
sure that every kid for the future that
school will be out of play an instrument
Peter Peter I love your story Peter from
Kenya was working at a private school
and decided to leave their private
school to give his talents to children
who were not getting the same level of
education that were getting at the
private school this particular area he
worked in had suffered under very severe
conflict in 2007 it was very violent
many of those kids were traumatized
families were traumatized
you started a Peace Club I knew I was
going to outrun the music sorry guys
like it's Melissa's fault it's not my
fault I'm sorry yeah let's just play it
again that's okay sorry you started a
Peace Club you also teach the adults if
they want to learn anything about
agriculture whatever it is you started a
science club and the kids who worked
with you with hardly any materials went
on to win the major prize in Africa for
the best science prize that was because
of you Peter not only that not only that
Peter donates 80 percent of his salary
back to the community not only that here
to share with me last night that up
until yesterday he'd never been on a
plane in his life and you've arrived in
a country that feels like you're in
heaven on another planet
SWAT up SWAT oh we have something in
common we worked in the movies however
you made the wise decision to get out of
it at age 37
one of the biggest Bollywood stars she
had been Miss India but really what she
wanted to do is teach so at age 37 she
left and has been teaching thousands
upon thousands of kids through drama how
to about themselves really you connect
to every single child you travel India
you give you teach them how to tell
stories and you teach them to connect to
yourself it's extraordinary
Vladimir Vladimir when I saw the video
about you and the smile you have on your
face every single day and how you create
a safe space for those kids to be able
to talk about whatever is going on in
their life in is it it's in Georgia Chat
Chat Chat what's the Chettiar what's the
name of your town a town home town I'm
sorry my Georgian is really bad I'm
sorry don't worry it's a lot to take in
but he if you must watch this video to
see how these kids are not just going to
school they are thriving at school and
on top of that he looks after eight
orphans at home
yesterday we have two things in common
we're both Aussies and both our sets of
parents emigrated to Australia yours
came a vary from a very difficult
situation in sri lanka they fled
violence at the time and you arrived and
felt so grateful of the opportunities
that you'd had growing up in australia
that you dedicated your life to serving
particularly communities of migrants and
refugees making sure that they have all
the opportunities that you were given
when coming to australia it's
extraordinary
you all teach us so many lessons so many
important important lessons most of all
you teach us how to give life to our
dreams
so tonight on behalf of the world
students and on behalf of anyone
anywhere around the world that cares
about our future we say thank you
so are you ready all right okay guys
here it is your highness your
excellencies ladies and gentlemen the
time has come the winner of the global
teacher prize for 2019 is
Peter to bocce
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
congratulations Peter
[Music]
I I would now like to invite I would
like to invite His Highness Sheikh
Hamdan bin Mohammed bin Rashid Al
Maktoum and mr. sunny Varkey to the
stage to present the trophy to the
winner
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you your highness and sunny if
your continued support of the teaching
profession
[Music]
[Applause]
and my economy group but of terrific
[Music]
thank you so much thank you your
highness Thank You mr. Bochy now
stay no no no stay stay stay up here
stay up here and it's okay stay up here
with Peter I'm sure he wants your
support
so Peter congratulations before I give
you this microphone to say a few words I
have a surprise for you we have a very
special video message just for you if
you have a look up on the screen on
behalf of all Kenyans let me
congratulate you on winning the global
teacher prize for this year you are a
shining example of what the human spirit
can achieve not just for Kenya
not just for Africa but for the world
Peter you chose to teach in a remote
part of Kenya Kiriko mixed a secondary
school and you chose to transform lives
in such situations a choice that I'm
sure was difficult
you give me faith that Africa's best
days are ahead of us and your story will
light the way for all future generations
in your Highness Sheikh Mohammed bin
Rashid Al Maktoum your support for the
teaching profession and your continued
patronage of the global teacher prize is
changing the lives of many teachers and
children around the world I also
recognize the contribution of mr. sunny
[ __ ] the Varkey foundation and all those
who have made
this celebration possible your
commitment to education throughout the
world is commendable to all our
finalists and to each and every
dedicated teacher around the world let
me say the future of our planet the
future of our young people is in your
hands and we will support you in
achieving this noble goal
congratulations to all and especially
thank you congratulations Peter
your highness excellencies ladies and
gentlemen we were now like to hear a few
words from the winner of the 2019 global
teacher prize Peter to be Qi
thanks so much thanks so much I didn't
expect this
it is surprise a great surprise not just
for me not just for Kenya no just for
Africa for the whole world
this shows that teachers matter teachers
matter teaching is a noble profession
His Highness Sheikh Mohammed bin Rashid
Al Maktoum 5 vice president and prime
minister of UAE and ruler of Dubai San
[ __ ] the founder of the fact foundation
ladies and gentlemen I am pleased
cornered and humbled to be awarded the
global teacher prize
I appreciate this great recognition on
behalf of all the hard-working teachers
throughout the world I salute all the
global teacher prize nominees or my
friends here present on the other yes
and the other teachers who have
transformed and are still transforming
the lives of Lana's and that of the
society in different ways in a special
way let me recognize the fact foundation
team for this wonderful initiative I
also must appreciate my pharaoh
Franciscan brothers and everyone who
supported eliminated or inspired me in
one way or another very special thanks
to my school curricula secondary school
including my piss-poor means that Danny
Rimer arey who is here with us fellow
teachers very very clearly teaches that
all the time.i we work together closely
support staff Palance students for their
animals support my thanks also goes to
the teacher service commission of kenya
for their great support
kindly kindly allow me to share my story
I was raised in a family of teachers in
macaron cozy village which is within who
zealand Kenya Africa growing up with his
main challenges I lost my mother at the
age of eleven after this my father a
primary school teacher had to do
everything for the sake of the family
including
preparing meals and catching us items
like Justin sympathize with him you just
ask him shall I just assist you to
prepare the meals educating us and most
importantly which has just came to
reflect just the other day that it was
the most important thing most
importantly in steering morale and a
Christian for use in us very strong
Christian and and that's why I find
myself to be a brother for the sake of
the community and they walnutrij he told
us to be hard-working humble god-fearing
chinless selfless and resilient ladies
and gentlemen my father mr. Lawrence
cebiche younger
my father mr. Lawrence the Pachanga is
with us today Papa Papa please stand up
[Applause]
he has been an ascetic man or through is
still old but not all very strong does
much machete
thanks so much thanks so much
[Applause]
did marvelous he did great work thank
you thank you thank you let us recognize
him and all those who have some before
us thank you thank you so much ladies
and gentlemen Carrico secondary school
is a church in pawnee village Nakuru
County Kenya in Africa it is lokay is
located in a remote semi-arid part of
Kenya through safari he has students
struggle to learn in a
resource-constrained environment and
come from diverse cultural riches and
needy backgrounds I was moved by the
difficult situation of the needy people
in Pune village and felt like I could
over some help
so I decided to stretch and show love to
this wonderful community through
teaching when I joined the school I met
a community of dedicated and hardworking
teachers students and others
stakeholders we work together to focus
on finding solutions to many challenges
we are so far succeeded in uniting the
school and the local community by
introducing the Peace Club we have
inspired students to participate in
talent nurturing club and science club
to create an opportunity for them to
explore and express the Italian talents
and abilities I must say I am very
excited that the majority of the
students who have been shining in most
of these activities are Eagles
these grapes as we seek to get more
girls focused on STEM subjects ladies
and gentlemen the value of a teacher
cannot be measured in terms of the
monthly salary what matters is the
passion and dedication with which we
serve our lana's because we were to be
paid it will in terms of millions we do
great work let every learner appreciate
the fact that everyone was born for a
reason and that feeders are a part of
life if you don't fail
you don't learn and if you don't learn
you'll never change and that challenges
and failures make us strong people
through them we become creative in the
process of trying to find solutions let
us always remember when you promote
education you are empowering the society
and changing the world for the better
thank you so much and may God bless you
thank you so much
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen it's the world that
these kids and kids like them all around
the world are gonna make because of the
teachers of the world will you please
give these kids a massive round of
applause how many guys
he's highness excellencies ladies and
gentlemen thank you very much to the
teachers of the world and particularly
our finalists congratulations thank you
so much to the Bakke foundation what do
we say kids
[Applause]
[Music]